if if netflix is going to buy this
special they're going to be like
he shot a netflix special and you want
to know something had
netflix said okay in the normal way
you know and just on the they wouldn't
have done it they wouldn't have put that
into it yeah
they wouldn't have allowed you yeah that
kind of
expenditure and i know because when you
did uh
is coming in the hawaii one you showed
me you came to
this office yeah and you showed me
before and i was amazed when we walked
out i was talking to rich about it after
how much um can i tell you something
about that one too
yeah so when live from seattle when i
gave them the final cut they bought it
they bought it right in the room they go
don't shop it around we want it
which was crazy and then uh and then i
got coming in hot
after that and uh and coming in hot they
gave me they gave me a nice chunk
right of money and i still dipped into
my pocket
and paid for coming in hot i still went
into my pocket
and you were sitting there people think
i made money on netflix i made
zero money on netflix but you're not
smart enough but my third and fourth i
made money
but one and two but ultimately you won
the investment but the big money is the
live
yeah in music too exactly it's the same
thing so these are great promotional
pieces for you to make and not only to
make money on live
yeah but speaking of live so spielberg
saw coming in yeah and he gets a call
from silver isn't that crazy
yeah isn't that crazy and that and what
makes me
it was kind of like this
means a lot to you yeah because it's
like it's like
years man like you know but and
you know you hear no for so long and
it's like what do you got to do what do
you what are you talking about specific
what are you talking none nothing made
sense
you know and then when you get someone
like spielberg watching it
and getting it then you're like okay so
what what were you guys saying again
because mr hollywood
got it he got it so i don't understand
what
you guys didn't get so slow down a
minute so you how did you get the call
how does the call come in
he he he called okay so he called
everyone at amblin right
and said watch this special coming in
hot he was shooting west side story
and uh he shot uh he took a break and he
was watching
coming in hot and uh wow why am i all
why are you guys all emotional right now
dude because and you know what
it's just it doesn't matter and that and
it's great because
the reason that you are the star you are
the reason that you have
the success that you have there are
people
that in this business in every business
that just do it because i gotta go to
work and i'll go do the work and don't
care about the work i've never met
somebody as passionate as you about what
you do
how it's received what it means to you
what the plan is how detailed you are
when it means something to you
and whether it goes bad or goes great it
hits your heart
and and listening to you and the emotion
of it
even makes it stick more so let's let's
go back to that moment so you're
he took a break he's watching coming in
hot where are you